hello everyone this is samir from audio
science review
i thought i'd get back to doing some
reviews as the name indicates
and uh sort of covers some of the
products that i reviewed during the last
week or so
um out of that i thought i'd pick the
hi-fi man
and on the headphone mostly because
uh when i wrote the review people seemed
to have
walked away with slightly different
impression that i wanted them to
take away from the review so let's go
over it
the headphone itself i think is the
largest
that i've ever tested you can see these
massive cups in here
and when i try to mount this on my uh
headphone fixture i don't know if you
can see in the front here but
it actually has a curve going inside
this is somebody's headphone
and maybe we would use it deformed i
don't know
but it actually you could see through it
to the
fixture so this was not a case of a uh
you know fully sealed headphone usually
my headphone
fixture fits better than you would
actually wear on your head but in this
case
uh there was a gap in there and that may
have impacted the measurements a bit
so um but overall though it was quite
easy to mount
and and make measurements when i say
easy it means
when i put it on i have my jig is a
stereo jig so the two channels matched
well and they match well
two different frequencies that i test
and i wasn't very picky about
how you mounted the headphone
if we look at the frequency response
compared to our preference curve
the dash blue is our preference curve
the first thing that jumps out at me is
just
amount of wiggliness in here uh many
headphones i test
sorry you can see my mouse usually
they're smooth
in this sort of uh upper base to uh you
know lower
uh treble or so uh not so here there's
just tons of variations and even within
the variations there are other
variations you can see the wiggliness is
just
quite high so to me it looks like this
drivers
is not well behaved that as you sweep it
from
you know one frequency the other like
this region is kind of smooth and then
it starts to pick up all these dips
you can see this better in this group
delay graph the group delay is hard to
interpret by itself as far as what the
values mean but generally you want to
have an exponential decay
going to zero here and we see that
there's just a tons of messiness
now many headphones have some amount of
messiness especially in the middle
but this thing is just messy across the
board the only area that's not messy is
this one area that was smooth everything
else from
low base to i mean i don't know where
you hang your hat on
typically this gets messy if you have
multiple
more than one source of sound um meaning
the two
are are out of phase with each other and
uh you get cancellations and additions
and the phase basically gets destroyed
when we measure speakers in the room
same thing happens sound bounces off the
walls
changes the timing they all combine
together and really create a mess in
there
luckily our ears aren't very sensitive
so we don't hear all these ups and downs
but it does indicate a driver that's
just not comfortable producing a full
range
my guess is that to make a driver this
big
it's got some resonances and modal
responses within that large driver
they're just out of control
on this thing and uh you know their he6
headphone did quite well in my testing
but
this one i just feel like either
interest of cost or just
bigger is better it was the number one
priority
it just objective measurement tends to
indicate that
um it just has quite a
bit of roughness in its response
literally and and
and objectively um there is a bass droop
in here and there was this is where
everybody got fixated over but it's
really between 20 and 30 hertz
and uh it could be because of the gap as
i mentioned
uh people went crazy thinking the whole
thing must be no good but
it's a slight gap and i mentioned that
in the review that
i actually try to squeeze it and and get
that out of there and it just made this
curve worse but since it's such a small
region it's really not
material on that front the other thing
that was disappointing was this just
level distortion
of headphones are supposed to be very
low distortion devices
but again here we see this incredible
business in here
and again in higher frequencies and
if we go back to frequency response or
here we see this
it's all in the same regions where you
know distortion is going nuts here
and also going nuts here and you can see
all the roughness in here
as a side note when you look at other
people's measurements you never see
these things
because they highly smooth these graphs
either they smooth them
or they average a bunch of them or they
make this vertical scale
very large some go as high as 100 db
vertically and when you do that
you squash the graphs and you make them
look very smooth
i don't do that i want to know what the
driver is doing i want to know the
sources of distortion
and so allow you to see this little
wiggleness
even though from tonality point of view
you want to sort of step back and ignore
that
but from a micro view it just it's one
of the i would say i don't know if the
right word to use
but it's the dirtiest driver that i've
measured uh
maybe the abyss that i measured was was
just as bad i don't know that actually
had more distortion than this one
but it's just not good you know
headphones really need to be low
distortion
they're moving tiny amount of air inside
your ear
and they should be able to do that very
little distortion now the
green curve is at 140 114 db spell so
it's quite loud
but you know if you look at it other
headphones they don't have these
these trends and that's what the these
three steps show you
at 94 104 and 114 is that
how bad is is distortion progressing and
we can see that
these are really the problem areas and
we push the driver just a little bit
more
it just the driver goes nuts at the
lowest level
even the 94 db which is to me is just
average to slightly below average
listening level we see that it just
struggles to stay below my
reference of 40 db and at some
frequencies it actually goes way past
that
so to me it's just not an acceptable
performance
uh on this thing um one advantage of
this planar magnetic headphones is that
there
basically is a trace on a piece of mylar
so it's acts like a
resistor and so the impedance is flat
is basically resistive so it's easy to
drive
and uh and the impedance is low meaning
that you need a lot of current to drive
it
relatively speaking um the headphone
itself is quite sensitive it only needs
93 millivolts to produce this 94 db spl
you can see in this graph of you know
where we are and some crazy stuff
out here like the hifiman's ag6 at the
other extreme
requires 1250 in this one basically 100
so
he6 requires 12 times more power than
this so it's quite
a bit more efficient it's more efficient
than the popular hd uh
650 from sennheiser about three times
more efficient so
this you can power with uh you know even
a standard phone or
you know anything you have out there it
should not be very taxing
on this thing so i went ahead and did
some listening tests and i got to tell
you one of the advantage of these such
big cups
is that you get this really nice spatial
quality special quality means not
everything's sort of
you know crammed in the middle of your
head but because of these cups and they
sort of stand proud
you get a lot of the sound stage outside
of your head which with headphones i
find that is critical
otherwise you get that terrible
headphone sound that's that's quite a
bit worse than the experience you get
with speakers
so that effect comes across and i think
a lot of the positive reviews that you
see out there is people
mesmerized by that effect and i can't
deny
the attractiveness of that that effect
this is quite a beautiful effect
and i praise it when i find it and this
is right up there
on that but uh you know i'm trying to
just
think past that and sorry how's the
tonality highest overall sound
and i find that the frequency response
basically told the truth
that everywhere that there was a hole
you needed to lift that up and anywhere
there are peaks
you want to pull those down and in my
case i found it you know sounding
somewhat bright
and that's up all those you know
resonances down in highs
and i give you some sub bass boost this
is where people argue they say well if
you didn't
if you had a perfect seal then you
wouldn't have shown the droop and this
wouldn't be necessary
my answer to them is on earth do you get
something this big to
fully seal around your your face i think
it won't see or certainly in my case it
needed the sub bass so
maybe with my face it didn't fit either
on this thing
once you have this equalization it
sounds quite good so now you get totally
correct
with this beautiful spatial effects you
know combined together
um but as i listen to it longer and
longer it just there was this sense of
fidelity that was missing and this is
purely subjective and it may be totally
nonsense
from objective point of view but you
know the listening test started
listening to us i'm sharing with you
what i found usually when i have
spectacular headphones
i continue to listen to them well past
the review i almost don't want to put
them down to go take pictures
on this thing but i found that uh
you know on these i just you know once i
turned the level down and i was just
listening to it while i was working i i
didn't enjoy it i took them off and
and that was that so um on this thing so
i'd say
you know clearly they focused on the
psychoacoustic effect of having massive
drivers
uh basically two little speakers hanging
from each side of your ear
and i think that's clever and i think it
works it's a thousand dollar headphones
so
you get a bit of magic there outside of
that i really think
unless the company can prove to me
otherwise that there's a pure driver
that is tasked with producing 20 to 20
000
without doing weird things in between
and build up
modal resonances in different parts of
the driver uh
it doesn't seem like they've ironed out
all the kinks there
pun intended and i encourage them to go
back and and find these sources of these
things and and fix them
or something because i think this
headphone
without those flaws who could be
incredible headphone
uh because you have that spatial effect
and if you get rid of the distortion and
everything else
it could be just beautiful um a lot of
people have come out
after the review and said oh it sounds
wonderful i've compared it with bunch of
other headphones i know all about
headphones and it sounds great
i can't tell you that you're not
enjoying it
that way because again the spatial
effects are quite good
without eq is actually acceptable
there's some headphones without eq
i just can't listen to them at all this
one's fine
but with eq it gets a lot better i've
encouraged people to go
plug in these these bands these seven
bands which i don't like i usually think
headphones should need two or three
filters and that should be it
to need this many to make it acceptable
is not good but
if you have the ananda i highly
encourage you to go ahead and try this
eq and
and post your uh you know what you think
in the comments
uh know that i'm not gonna try to argue
with you if you say you love it it's the
best thing you've heard i
i've heard it and i know people like it
my job is to
you know be critical enough to find
differentiation between headphones and i
tell you
there's a difference between two
headphones where one of them is follows
the exact same tonality but doesn't have
all these chewed up stuff
there's no question that all these
chewed up variations are impacting the
music you're hearing it just you can't
say that well
that stuff doesn't exist it does exist
it's got ups and downs it's got
you know group delay it's got distortion
so it's
it's a flawed headphone it's just
there's no way
to get around it's a flawed headphone
but it may just have
you know other attributes that you enjoy
having then i'm not gonna argue
with that um so that's it uh
hope you got something out of this uh
review if you're interested in this
headphone
i've got bunch more i'll do another
headphone review right after this one a
different model
okay see you in another one bye-bye